don't take a picture let's get boy hey
I'm Leticia right and today I'm gonna
find out which Black Panther lady I am
I'm better be Sheree what do you value
most in your friend kindness loyalty
smarts humor it's between kindness and
loyalty I only have to pick one right
kindness choose a black pants a guide to
be your sidekick kill monger pick a
superhero ability super strength
teleportation invincibility to mind
stuff which technology is the coolest
seriously you're gonna put Iron Man's
Technology next door what continent I
need to teach you guys an omelet call
you you can control remotely from
anywhere I'm never gonna look at the
rest what scares you the most getting
old dumb people that's a rude failure
darkness failure scares me the most
pick a Marvel Universe location to live
in or kinda wait guess what I've got
I'm sure II I'm so happy
thank you lord okay so says everyone has
a black panther lady who matches their
personality here's your's
you got Sheree yes you're highly
intelligent and you are often the one
you people come to for answers or help
with their problems some may say you
come off as a look you're just like that
because you don't have time for nonsense
exactly exactly
you're too busy creating and being
brilliant in general hey a tight knit
group of friends I do I keep a tight
knit group of friends and consider
yourself very close to your family
this is actually me this is actually
scary yeah
mm-hm I'm Cherie yes I must be happy
because if I was someone else I would
kind of for your computer array down
there I'm sure you don't take a picture
Liz yeah boy
guys this means that I'm Marvel higher
me next time
[Music]